last session so we have had a wonderful
or two days already this is our last
session we usually say best for the last
so
our first speaker for this afternoon
session is professor yajin wong from
the study department at the university
of wisconsin medicine and yazon was also
peter's student so but i i don't know
young
young number you know a long time still
that is yeah and yeah he's also
currently the department chair at the
university of wisconsin at medicine so
yeah john flores yours thank you
well thanks hiya for the introduction uh
according to the uh the student the
peter lisa on his web page i'm the
number 39
and so it's
that's the sources i know there's some
kind of ambiguity or the missing data
but that my source is from the hidden
webpage so i'd like to thank peter for
the uh uh many years inspiration and
help and support and uh to my uh career
and thanks peter happy birthday
and i also like to thank the uh
organizer for uh putting together this
conference and uh for inviting me for
this opportunity to give a talk and uh
uh another things i like that you think
is the simon institute and they
organized the institute institute
organized many quantum computing
programs over the year
i participated many
in person before the pandemic and uh
even more during the pandemic uh field
of zoom and i feel is the kind of
wonderful benefit maybe for the coving i
can kind of move freely to attend those
uh those uh quantum computing uh
programs
so i will uh
for this today's audience i feel is for
the statistics audience and i will i
know the the barrier about the quantum
computation and the concept i will try
to use a minimal introduction of quantum
computations to illustrate my point
uh i i will keep like the focus at about
my pocket at high level for the simple
cases so that we can better understand
uh understand the uh uh the things from
the statistics aspects
now uh what's the uh like first let's
talk about the quantum advantage or the
quantum uh
supremacies
uh the way we think of like when you
compare quantum uh device combination
device usually you do a theoretical
proof okay on the theory another one is
to build up device for the experimental
demonstration okay now for quantum cases
over the years there's a lot of like a
theoretical
study proposing uh quantum algorithms
and actually you can prove uh there are
many quantum algorithms which can be uh
much faster than the classical
algorithms like a well-known like for
example shorts are factoring large
numbers and
the algorithms which has been proving uh
to be exponentially fast than the best
known classical algorithm okay
also the groove uh search algorithms
which you can uh have been showed is uh
quadrotically fast to the best proofed
aggregate classical algorithms and
actually the quadrotic fast is the
optimal and that so basically it has
been optimal in the quantum sense
opening in a classical sense and you can
compare to still have a quadruple speed
up now we have all of those theories uh
method algorithm proved in based on
quantum theory now
well we demonstrated can we demonstrate
that one so we needed to build up a
device try to run these algorithms to
actually see what happened and there so
in principle we could do is try to
fight build up a device
try to uh compete against the best super
computer i need to see what happened
there okay now unfortunately uh uh
because of the technology difficulty
what we can uh created are the quantum
computers uh a much smaller uh scale and
which cannot run those uh kind of like a
theoretically proving uh algorithms and
to show those quantum advantage
so
the way is can we based on what we have
do something completed with the best i
like that super computer which is the
similar to like we show like the apple
cars against the laptop and you try to
find out some algorithms uh some
computational problems you run on both
to see what happens okay now uh for the
case for the cases the fundamental
computing cases against the best
supercomputer it's basically pretty much
the same of this comparison it's just to
try to uh find out suitable problems uh
to demonstrate uh some of the things and
you may have heard about it that like
the recent
landmark
project
demonstrating quantum supremacies
basically saying
take 200 seconds computational job for
the fundamental computer and that one
would take 10 000 years or 0.6 billion
years uh for this best super computer at
that time and you finished at the 200 uh
200 second job and the fundamental
computer did
so the two uh project one is the google
and the publishing nature uh it's
basically they find out uh
so-called uh random quantum circuits
what's that one it is a statistic
assembly problem which i will illustrate
and at the moment and basically show
that one at that time the best
fundamental computer as best the
classical super computer would take it
ten thousand years and the second
project that we
is
published in the science uh 2020s by a
ustc china and uh project the base build
up another quantum computer and
again a statistic example sampling
problems is called both on sampling and
they showed for data that that problem
it would take the computational uh
problem it would take the best of the
super computer
at that time to
take maybe that point six billion years
to finish that job
so
so what i will illustrate in my talk is
trying to explain the statistics and uh
associated with those projects
now uh i have to to say that one is when
i refer to classical computer okay and
it means what we are currently using a
electronic base okay and the second one
i like to
like it and say that one is although we
call it quantum computer like a classic
computer both a computer and either
you be may not believing that the
difference between the quantum computer
and the current classical computer is
much bigger than
that these two like the uh the laptops
and accuracy because of the functioning
underlying mechanism
so let's uh go down to the bottom and
see what's the uh quantum computing uh
it's basically it's like the classical
computing all started with bits like
zero and one and in the quantum cases we
have a quantum beat and we call it qubit
and it's also zero and the one we use
this uh cat these kind of like notations
uh to to change it in the quantum bit
okay
now unlike it in the in the in the uh
classical cases you only have these two
points quantum theory allow us uh qubit
in the superposition state is basically
you have a different one any linear
combination of these is also a state
and
so that that those two coefficients are
amplitude they have these kind of unit
normal constraints okay
and uh in a moment you will see this
will have that probability sticks and uh
consequence uh for for for for the uh
rental nature of the quantum cubit
theory
now if you from these superpositions you
can see if you identify those two or the
base okay so any linear combinations of
this one superposition state
corresponding a point in the two
dimensional space okay
so the superpositions is corresponding
all of those
fields at the point every point
corresponding to a state unlike the
classic classification they only got a
two point is in the classical cases
either on or off like a coin like a pro
and the cons okay now in the quantum
cases you can think about it that coin
which have all the state
from the pro and anything continues and
and of this one so you will see that in
the much bigger space okay now because
of the superpositions you can think of
interpret that one is uh in the
classical cases either head or tail okay
and uh in that quantum case you can have
a both head and tail both zero and one
cases continue into the simultaneously
now
in the classical cases we now it is zero
and one and uh
you know which state is you always easy
to check now in the quantum cases you
cannot directly exempt the qubit to find
out those coefficients but there is a
you can measure that qubit and then
there's a stochastic random outcome here
so what happens is if you make any
measurement of the qubit what you would
see it will be collapsed to the two
points
beta 0 and 1 in the random cases now
what's the probability of observation 0
is that corresponding coefficient
amplitude a modulus square okay and the
with 1 is
for this coefficient modulus well so
that's the constraint of equal to one
allow these probability uh
interpretations that's well uh the
probability uh comes into play in the
quantum and in the cubic cases so
remember that one is anything you have a
qubit you want it it will if you wanted
to do measurements and get a result like
the like digits and then there's a
probability there okay you can think
about the probability distribution and
because of this one all the quantum
computations algorithms and things are
random algorithms and the distribution
associated with that one okay
now moving to the multiple qubits okay
and in that two cubic cases you would
see there will be four of them zero zero
zero one one zero zero one one okay so
that any superposition will be
linear combination of those four so if
you think about those are the bases it
occurs the space you need to handle the
two grouping it'll be four dimensions if
you have three cubits eight animation so
uh if you have a vehicle it will be true
to the power of b dimension you can see
the exponential scale up okay the
superposition expansion scale so that's
the uh cubic
now uh similar to that to the classical
computer cases we need to build up a
gate circles uh to get make the
computation moving so in the quantum
cases you can also uh build up the gates
and like for example you can change the
zero to one one to zero okay but
remember we have a superposition okay so
the quantum theory is saying that all
the cubic degrees are must be unitary
the transformation must be unit of any
of this one unlike the classic basic it
must be unitary and that one is
represented by a unitary matrix okay so
that any of these you would see uh
compare with this one you transform the
state and then any supervision will
happen same with similar transformations
these are unitary matrix so if you think
about a gate is a unitary matrix okay
now the circuits quantum server it's
just connecting a circuit of a gates
together quantum gates together okay uh
so that one is this circuit is kind of a
performing uh if you carry out this
circuit and do a bunch of those unit
universal information you are performing
the certain computational task and that
task basically if you you can think
about all those connected if each of the
gates have a unitary matrix you multiply
together so you will have a big unitary
matrix for these circuits so in the end
you want to see whenever we talk about
the circles you can think about a unit
or matrix big unit or matrix
corresponding to that one okay and
so this is the combination now what's
the exciting uh oh here is just some
pictures illustrated that the cube is
here and you can apply the case and you
can uh
one or two cases and if you carry all of
them it corresponds to a quantum circuit
now what's exciting about it the quantum
computation is the possible
speed up of fast algorithm to uh
performing certain computational tasks
which is due to the many quantum uh
property which is in the classical cases
we don't have like supervisions
entanglements and so on and so forth so
if you have any algorithms uh on the on
the buildup on the circuits uh carry out
that one you'll have under result
automation everything is random okay so
it's basically it's like the mcmc
algorithms your real ones it may give
you the correct or incorrect solution
okay but there is certain probabilities
you will get the correct solution okay
so you now you repeat you'll eventually
get the correct solutions so that any
algorithms correspond the end result
will have a probability that the retinal
outcome solutions they will be have a
distribution associated with that one
okay
now
when we say the compile compare the
classical computer and uh and the
quantum computer you would see uh what's
the against these two it's basically
that using
you're using the classical computer to
solve a class a computational problem if
the problem is the same you just use the
given device to solve the same problem
okay now the classical computer can only
run the classical algorithm
quantum computer can need to run the
quantum algorithm
now the speed up of the mission that is
the uh the interesting about these
things is that potential quantum speed
up there are many theoretically proven
quantum algorithms which has uh have uh
speed up uh over the classical algorithm
and i wanted to put that one not always
as a matter of fact and the many cases
we don't fundamental computers don't
have to speed up it's just for certain
problems it may have
quantum speed up
now again what's the issue here
is because we don't have the large scale
quantum computer to uh render
theoretically proven uh algorithms which
we can demonstrate the quantum advantage
and in the practice what we have is
pointed we can build up a strategy with
a much smaller quantum computer and
which may not be uh imperfect and we
refer to the near term quantum computer
we still wanted to find out some
problems
which we will be using
calculate like the
performing uh on the on the quantum
computer against the best supercomputer
to solve that kind of problems trying to
show there's a quantum advantage an
advantage so this is the kind will refer
to quantum supremacy okay
now uh the two uh projects automation
early on are the uh one is google
another one is the uh ustc projects and
google they build up a quantum computer
is based on the super conducting and
qubits with the 53 cubits at that time
and the designer problems is uh either
refer to the random quantum circles and
the statistical sampling problems and
the rent on this uh on this uh this
device and and that you solve that
problems and you will see i would in a
moment i will explain what's the random
quantum surface
and the usgc is based on the uh optic
quantum optic systems uh photons and uh
buildup uh is uh
it's in the 20th 2020s and uh they also
uh solved our sampling problems and i
will explain this one what's that bozon
random sample uh both on sampling
problem there are both are statistical
problems to solve for that one now why
they choose assembling problems uh
automating that one that because of a
limitation the quantum computer so far
we have is relatively small and
it's uh it's noisy and so we needed to
find out the problems are very suitable
for those device okay to to perform but
on the other hand we wanted to use that
problem it's very hard for the super
computer okay to solve so we can
demonstrate advantages so that the two
things so easy relatively easy for the
quantum computer and the very hard for
that uh super computer
now let's let's explain what's the uh
random quantum service and basically
that the google computer we have at that
time have 53 qubits basically you have
all those qubits they apply the gates
okay randomly select those gates apply
on these each of those qubits from a set
of gates apply on the other one and
these stop
the other other single qubit and those
one are the like two cubits basically
you can think about it's kind of like
that uh like it's like the unit of a
matrix multiply on a cubic basis and
they will repeat okay you think about
one round then regular sampling another
round and they're giving the m wrong so
why they do the div even wrong because
they wanted to increase complexity
increase the hardness for the classical
computer to do the sampling okay
now in the end after you apply all those
gates
the quantum circuit that the qubits in
this quantum computer in this
case you make measurements okay you will
get the sum of the each cubic that will
be one zero or one so in the end you
will get like in this case the 53 length
of one zero bit stream okay so that's
supposed to get that that's your data
okay so in this case if you have a b
bits those bit string will be belong to
this space length of a b and zero one
okay now how many number of this one is
two to the power for b so exponential uh
increase you want to see if you make
these these
like the bigger
eventually and make these steps like the
cycles more
eventually you will make it so hard for
the super computer to calculate the
simulated leads okay now for the quantum
computer what you do is you just carry
out this one in the end make a
measurement you will get the data okay
so if it turns out these problems can be
illustrated of the size biased sampling
uh uh approach scheme in that cases it's
just in this probability space okay this
way the probability space do the
sampling now what's the sampling in this
case remember for each realization of
these reynolds you have a circle you can
make measurements there is a probability
distribution over there okay and then
there's another layers of because we
apply those gates random okay so there's
another randomness there the two layers
of retinol means there so it's like it's
like the uh two layers of reynolds so
you you know make that the classical
combination so hard
because of that one so there is idealize
the cases like they can make it argue
that one if that adapts go to infinity
and you will approach it your so-called
the asymptotics is the ideal product
times
distributions in that case now what is
the scheme
you can see this corresponding to if you
trade this
this circuit is corresponding a unitary
matrix on the 2b times the 2b although
the unitary matrix is this one this
idealized as a methodical limit sense
either corresponding to a you if you put
a higher measure on these all of those
unitary matrix and you sample according
to this how measure okay and what what
happened in that one
each fixed sample of the qubits
sorry unitary matrix corresponding one
realization of these qubits you make the
measurements basically that they order
the cubits in those states so if you
make a measurement you observe any of
the bit string in this space it will
correspond in the probability of an
amplitude square automation early on now
differentiated here this amplitude is
also random okay there's another retinal
knee scale so we'll call the random
circuits so this renault knees under the
idealized cases in illustrator at this
point you sample iid from exponential
distribution okay and then they
normalize this one and make this
amplitude square corresponding to this
probability
okay so what happened is that observed
data is the bit stream it's essentially
uh the bit stream uh those bit string
you're observed according to this
probability two layers of probability
scheme and in these cases okay space now
as i mentioned that our cubits are not a
perfect they're the law is still this is
the ideal case you have this probability
distribution of quantities actually
there is added additive noise there so
that in the real cases corresponding
this one the model is this probability
observed those strings is equal to some
epsilon times the idealized probability
plus one minus epsilon and here we put
some noise and this one is the uniform
noise on this space okay so that is this
epsilon is the fidelity basically the
measure uh what's the uh
like closeness of the sampling
distribution with this ideal
distribution or is it how many uh like
the percentage of the data streams are
really from the output distribution from
those uh carried out to the circuit
now if you forget about all those
quantum lists you can summarize in the
idealized case what's the sampling
problem the sampling problem is like a
biased assembly you have this
probability space discrete with the
cardinality of the equal to b okay you
have a sampling scheme the assembling
scheme is basically is all of those bit
string in this space you draw one of
each of those bit string is according to
this probability okay now what's this
probability is the weight of this
uniform and those from the exponential
okay carry out the probability okay the
issue is uh the b increase okay the real
problem is the size increase as the
depth increase the simulated this board
using that classical computing is so
hard remember the classical computing
you when you need a sample from
something that you need to know the true
distribution okay to find out what's the
true distribution it's very hard so hard
as you increase the b and that in an
increase m at that time the best the
super computer can do is about it at b
equal to around 50 m is about a 20 okay
beyond that one we don't in principle
there is the truth there but we don't
know and and in the super computer
cannot calculate that one remember the
quantum computer do disassembly is
relatively easy they are not calculating
the underlying true probability
they just ran this process uh to get the
sampling okay so in a sense is that is
the physics okay now you would see that
when we talk about the computing
everything is about physics and because
we don't pay much attention if you do
the sampling and using our current
computer like mm mcmc basically you are
using the electronic physics to do that
simulate sampling and in this quantum
cases they use in the quantum theory to
calculate to do the assembly
so the cases here is that the sampling
problems also push this uh away it will
be so hard for the uh for the classical
building but quantum computing you can
sense that one is eventually we will
we'll get there demonstrate that things
uh similarly for the uh for the boson
sampling is using the uh the process
from the uh optical systems you build up
the photons passes through the beam
sleeve and uh
splitter and uh and the phone resources
feed split basically build up uh
operating systems and
there's a m like a photons passes
through this network at the end the
photons will be appear here and there
you'll find out where they are because
the retinal needs the location of this
you detect the location will have random
so the random there will be have a
underlying distribution okay and that
underlying distribution similar to the
random quantum surface is output
distribution okay now in this case i we
can write down exactly what's the output
distribution the sample space is
basically you assume that the m photons
and m mode and
also the state will be the m of those
digits and the only constraint is those
uh
number must be equal to total number of
and so you can easily find out the
cardinality of this one is equal to this
combinatorial number okay also
remember this
that this is the operating system is
that there is a urinary matrix
represented on these four systems like
the circuit cases so there is a unitary
matrix size of m times m and represented
the whole system okay now with those
things we can write down the probability
of the true probability distribution so
basically being each of those states
this way the probability is equal to
this denominator easy the numerator is
you're using this state
to from this this big matrix you've got
the sample matrix from this one then you
need to calculate the permanent okay not
a determinant permanent is like the
determinant except that the no signs
minus i plus j here the no signs it's
just all possible of all possible
summation over here so it turns out
unlike the determinant much easier to
calculate the permanent is the p
sharp
complete complete uh complexity it's
very hard so essentially it's the for
the quantum computer you just ran this
process you get the detected photons you
got the sampling but for the classical
computer in order to do the sampling you
need to calculate those probabilities
okay and then according to the
probability due to sampling and
calculating those probability is very
very hard so also we increase the
certain size of a certain point and you
will see the quantum computer the
classical computer won't be able uh to
do that one okay so this is the similar
the cases is the automation why those
are sampling are easy for the quantum
computer so hard for the classical
computer okay
now the one is uh here is you can see it
as we in principle right now as we're
pushing we can find out the way we can
move in these things to that regime that
is
part of
supercomputers won't be able to handle
within the intractable regime
now in that regime we don't know what's
the truth
because we cannot calculate quantum
computers simulate the samples now how
do we now you build up a quantum device
you draw some data okay and how do you
know this one is truly from that one the
distribution which we won't be able to
calculate
so that to to demonstrate the claim of
economists and premises you would need a
statistics okay again that's a statistic
to come to play is the one how do we
benchmarking to prove uh quantum speed
up in that case the sample you generated
from that device indeed is from the uh
true uh in targeted probability
distribution
now here there is the issue like you
have the input and you have a quantum
computer with resources you have the uh
input from a classical computer with
those uh resources you get an output
quantum cases the output following the
certain distributions and in the classic
phases you may use the randomization and
if it's another retinal and with the
distributions uh to indicate the quantum
speed up basically for the classical
computer you'll need much more resources
like the computing time piece and uh
those kind of things then the quantum
computer and then you can prove that
there is a uh there is a quantum speed
up now here automation how to uh prove
these cases uh we need to uh generate a
sample basically you need some kind of a
benchmark apply on those distributions
generate a result classical quantum
cases and those are the performance on
those benchmark two things we need to
show one is statistical efficiency
another one is the computational
efficiency what's the statistic
efficiency remember those quantum
distributions of distribution are grow
exponentially with the weightless with
the size so if you wanted to try to
estimate those distributions okay or
anything
uh like the
fancy enough for those distributions you
would needed an exponential uh sample
size to estimate those things so there
was the distinct efficiency we wanted
means it went only allowed to have a
polynomial
symbol size what would allow us to
estimate those things because in the
interactive regime we don't know the
truth we only have a sample from quantum
computer we need to use statistics to
estimate those benchmarks okay and you
will later on you will i will show that
on many like usual things won't be able
to have that uh that
statistic efficiency now for the
computational efficiency it means we can
calculate those uh benchmark in our
polynomial time okay what are the
explanation time so those one are the
issues associated with that one
now in this very simple cases in the
factoring problems they you can easily
say that both statistical and
computational division like if you go to
the integration of prime you put a
number there the solution in the correct
order just multiply those together
simply find out it's cracked or not and
so the computational efficiency is very
easy so the distribution is also easy
because you estimated those probability
you don't need a database experiment you
only needed a polynomial number of an
assembly to estimate those those things
now in the cases of the noise quantum
computer okay remember the one what do
we have it's not a perfect fundamental
computer it's the noise version instead
of the noise there so we can we can
define the similar case if you put a
star here to illustrate it they are the
noise version of the idealized cases
there is a noise uh version of that one
so we needed a benchmark we need to
apply the measure that noise uh like the
uh generate from noise quantum computer
generated data and the classical uh
generated data away
and again we need to handle statistical
efficiency and combination efficiency
for those uh benchmark uh automation if
you're using the usual things like for
example the distribution of these
distribution there's a true distribution
okay and of of this one for the truth
basically all of those targets we're
trying to looking for the true
distribution okay now if you're using
compare this one using all those
distance okay usual distance and it
turns out uh the proof basically using
the quantum thermography and audiencing
you would require exponential number of
sample size to and illustrate to
estimate those uh
those difference and and estimate so it
won't be a statistically efficient and
the google did define the so-called
cross uh entropy benchmark and using
some of the as a reporting like i
mentioned that tom's portland port
thomas regime distribution to come up
with that one we showed it's a it is a
statistical division that only needed
that polynomial sample to estimate this
benchmark
uh computationally none of them are
computationally efficient is because
quantum computer i'm not trying to
calculate the underlying true
distribution the classical computer
won't be able to calculate uh do the
sample calculate the true uh
distributions over the
for that for the over the like the
quantum supremacy regime like once at
that kind of intractable regime uh no
one knows what's the true underlying
output distribution so you can only like
stop this will will work so largely to
rely on the statistics you build up uh
using those samples but you didn't need
the calculator the two of them need to
calculate you need exponential number of
times so what you do you use in the
statistic data uh to build up statistic
models and do the extrapolations and
illustrate this point now whether this
is a case is sure that one is still
there that there's another uh uh enough
uh things to do research on this part so
this is the one of them that illustrate
uh that point how much time do you have
okay five minutes alright
so uh this is the basic uh uh scheme and
to study for this one now what's the uh
result like the the two uh project like
the google and ustc and they showed that
uh quantum supremacies so basically they
all of those results are amazing that
they are based on circumstantial uh
evidence because they're intractable
regimes we really don't know what's
what's the truth and uh on the other
hand we want to claim that
it will happen or that happened okay so
basically what they do is they build up
and use the engineer physics and
simplify the models and uh
collect the data and analyze what
happened in the interactive regime okay
and then trying to infer what happened
in the uh sorry tractable regime what
happened in the interactive regime you
see what happened there now in the like
the google studies they uh for these are
simplified like circles and they collect
the data sample and they're using quite
a sophisticated statistics based on 30
million of the data and in the end of
the estimate it is a benchmark and it's
0.2 uh percent what it means uh in that
sense the claim is about that uh 0.2
percent of the bit strings are truly
come from the idealized output
distribution okay now if you're using
the using the super computer okay
classical super computer trying to
generate a bit stream with match up with
at least with this kind of like that uh
like the uh fidelities like this much of
the data come from output distributions
uh they illustrate that one is with a
different with 53 uh qubits okay fifty
three cubes remember that uh is the
stated omega is the two to the power of
53 that's a big size okay and with the
depth 12 they were estimated two hours
to calculate this one and by the
classical computer
and increase based on these models
statistic confidence bootstrap all those
things now in the end of the estimate at
the trendiest that one we don't we the
supercomputer cannot calculate what
happened there the estimator build up
this model you see that one require 10
000 years to do that
like the sampling and the 200 uh a
second assembly december by the way one
minute one billion bit stream okay and
to assemble one billion businessmen it
will take the ten thousand years by the
uh ambassador super computer to that
time now again
if you wanted to calculate this one this
part is that really if you want to truly
calculate it you can see the break they
did in the calculator what happened it
would take millions millions of years
more years to actually you calculated
those uh underlying distribution this is
just the sampling project
now once this result published there's
many immediately like
like the challenge
reviewed about the claims result and
with the main is ranging from the device
noise the new algorithms come out and
the combination models the statistical
uh issues the evidence all of those
things are
related to that one and so there's a lot
of like the
debate
discussion and
continuing uh phone against on both
sides and about these are issues
now for the ustc project and they
actually argued uh is there's a 0.99 uh
percent of fidelity basically there's
not much noise they're trying to see
that in the simplified cases or the
smaller cases they can check with
against the underlying distributions and
find out very uh feet and then they just
said well in the in the
intractable regime should be should we
work and also the buildup for the
classical computings what's the time
required the sample data are 200 second
jobs and basically it estimated it will
be like that 0.6 billion years at the
best quantum computer okay now of course
those are tons of like issues and the
debate and even largely is because they
existing a wide range of uh
views about the quantum computing
ranging from the hype to the uh
skepticism of skepticism about the
fundamental complications and even for
these quantum supremacies uh they
illustrate even just from the purely
statistical point of views you would see
that a lot of like uh issues to be uh
resolved so if we expect a long-term
race between the uh fast like the
classical algorithms and the improved
device so it will be continue probably
until we build up a quantum computer
actually can run those like short
algorithms and that you immediately get
to to demonstrate that theoretically
proving advantage maybe at that point
things can be uh settled now this is
just one cases furthermore is that if
there's a lot of more of the interface
between the statistics and the
fundamental computer remember to build
up a quantum computer you are needed
like the many cases like that there's
quantum systems that so many parameters
models and you'll see involve a lot of
issues due to for building
uh for building quantum computing in in
the involved statistics and also you
build up the device you will see how do
now the device will performance
according to your design so that the
certifications based on the many uh
issues is highly related the quality
inference and
in that part so another on on the other
hand if we have uh
like the quantum computers you would see
the greater potential to revolutionize
many of the statistical computations and
the machine learning things
now much more of of the much beyond
these statistics and a lot of things
going on in that quantum computer thank
you
any questions for you adam
i really mean not true that i understand
you compel quantum
computer to general prepares computer
what you call classical general purpose
computer to be fair you have to compare
it to a silicon based machine that is
specially proposed built to solve a
specific problem
can you what would be the result then
that's a fair comparison otherwise i
would ask you to compare quantum
computer to leave computer which
is the best
computer i know to where to compute the
path of a leaf falling in the freezer
yeah that's real fair questions and i
think that the one we are not at that
stage i think because of that uh like at
this point we have all those theory they
are approved and we just people are
trying to say can you show some things
and in the in the in the real
calculations and this one again is just
one of the uh demonstrating the concept
maybe you can say in this like in the
statistic sense and uh uh to show that
either cases we can compute that one
like that that seems you you you
mentioned yes it failed but we are not
that yet far from there yet
okay so is there a program that people
can turn every classical algorithm with
a quantum computing computer algorithm
is there a systematic approach to do
that yeah it's basically that all the
classical algorithm can be traded as a
quantum algorithm
and because of that all those that like
a gate operation can be realized by the
quantum gate the real issue in the
quantum computation well in order to say
that that those can be feed to the
fundamental combination we are looking
for that fast speed
so if you can for the certain things
even because you can convert it that way
if it is no faster speed no speed up so
we don't lock it that way so we are
looking for the fast way you you can you
for the certain problem you do the
quantum ways can compute much faster
so you don't know which uh give your
argument you cannot tell me which ones
faster uh in in well the quantum
computer can never be slower than the
the classical computer because of
automation all those classical uh
algorithms can be traded to that uh
quantum algorithm
they cannot be slower but that whether
they can be faster or not it's it's
is it obvious it's more energy efficient
uh well that's no
yeah like the cost and uh like the cost
the energy efficiency that's not
effective
the
couple of slides back the the point two
percent um measure statistics that you
had would you call that good or
good or bad well uh the one is i the one
is remember the goal of that one is
trying to have some problems uh there's
no private practical purpose that can be
used in practice it doesn't create a
problem to demonstrate these concepts
yeah that's my question
so if we restrict our attention to
quantum supremacy experiments and
hopefully in the next few years there
are a couple more coming out what do you
think are the outstanding statistical
questions that needs to be answered that
haven't been answered so far in those
papers i feel that even for the quantum
supremacy uh project like for example
there is a lot of like that yeah if you
trying to let's say using that fda like
that in the pharmaceutical company we
develop a new drug way there's a lot of
statistics you go to the fda you need to
check all those analyses if you use that
one of the golden standard okay uh
probably many of those analyses won't be
able to pass that that'll stand up okay
so there's a ton of issue i think
probably that like for example in these
problems like in the google study
problems and like there's a noise model
for uh the noise model there right and
the quantum computer to generate the
data from that noise models and like i
and we and the others they try to look
at it does the data really feed it to
that the model the physical model there
does not statistically test basically
reject uh the hypotheses does not fit
into the model but we know now uh
because there's so many complicated
issues there and we we couldn't find out
any suitable model defeating the data
but on the other hand there's so many uh
automation that you should say yeah
that might be used to
guess what the life form of the noise
model of data beyond the global
depolarized error model yeah it's not a
i don't have a solution to that one
that's why we need more statisticians to
work in this field and hopefully
that
resolves many
so i see there are no more questions so
let's start together again for this